um yo I gotta ask you one random
question
on safehouse when you kept your running
out of breath in and then you re-hitched
your line was that what happened did you
run out of breath and you were like not
keep that in
so because just let me tell you my
perspective before you answer because
I'm thinking this guy's overweight yeah
I'm like it's one of the most fire
things I've ever seen an artist do
because you were just going in and then
you almost like kind of got winded and
you might not keep all that in and then
you picked it right back up okay so boom
if you watched the video you can't hear
me breathing them out so the the audio
they got dropped wasn't the the master
mix to master version so like you could
hear all of that extra stuff in the back
like you can hear me breathing heavy and
all of it but the YouTube version
wouldn't but it just so happened it went
crazy they loved it so oh it's so good
but was that what happened you read like
genuinely I ran out of breath but it was
I meant to like it was always meant for
me to come down this fat guy ever seen
an artist
I appreciate it
I think he didn't do that bro you know
but out of breath biggie was a big pun
was run out of breath they didn't keep
that dead I was like it's hard yeah man
I started off putting on for the Big
Fellas first putting out for the Big
Fellas my CD then
the state I appreciate you for wearing a
shirt I was I was afraid that if you
came here shirtless I was gonna then
take my shirt off so lately a lot of
people I can't go nowhere without my
shirt now like I walk in place my
manager's like all right come on give it
to me
what you talking about give me a shirt
they don't want you in there unless you
got your shirt off it's like your
trademark yeah so now it's like well if
that's what they want they got to pay
for it so now I try to go everywhere
with it straight on and they're like
come on man take it out and I'm like
what you want have you ever heard of the
comedian Bert Kreischer okay so he's
this white dude he's one of the biggest
comedians in the world
but he does all his stand-up he's a
chubby white dude he has to have a shirt
off it's like his thing everyone screams
like he almost can't do comedy with a
shirt on it's kind of he's kind of I
feel bad for him you made the right
choice to be like I'm gonna start
wearing it because then you're just
always going to be the naked dude yeah
yeah exactly I mean it was crazy I'm the
most comfortable naked I feel like I was
a nudist in my I was a nudist in my past
life I don't know about everybody else
but in my past life I was a naked man
for sure for sure for sure and so now I
don't know I just I've always been
comfortable like I was a football player
so I've always yeah been comfortable
just with my body like if I wanted to
right now I can go to the gym and I look
like got them a black Brock Lesnar you
know what I'm saying
I know Brock Lesnar as the UFC fighter I
know I watch wrestling I didn't I didn't
see him in the wrestling man I was a big
Randy Orton fan you know about the RKO
yes sir I used to I used to bang on the
floor and drool out of my mouth and yeah
and then hop up yeah I used to do that
got in trouble for it a lot but I used
to do his shirt off I mean you know
Stone Cold the goat is from Texas I just
I didn't like I don't like beer so I
never I never liked it when he did that
he nasty what do you drink
I just started drinking liquor now that
I'm like a a rapper I'm out all the time
right so now you're starting to drink
more yeah I drink once that first bottle
gone it's like we five bottles in now
but what are you drinking cause Amigos
yeah that repo is good yeah that's
that's the thing for me it used to be
Hennessy though but we used to shut down
every Club so we had to stop everyone
switched yeah yeah we had a lot less
violent of a drunk if you're off exactly
I'm fighting or I'm naked I'm I'm naked
bro both
no it's crazy um